anchored in the Red Sea off the coast of
Yemen super tanker fso Safa contains
over a million barrels of crude oil and
threatens to cause an environmental and
humanitarian disaster it was abandoned
nearly a decade ago due to the Civil War
and now it is falling apart a looming
catastrophe this fragile country cannot
afford
we don't want the Red Sea to become the
Black Sea that's what's going to happen
that's an ancient vessel a 1976 super
tanker therefore is not only all but
unmaintained and likely to think it or
explode at any moment the UN is so
desperate to stop the oil spilling that
it has crowdfunded the purchase of a
rescue tanker to go on a salvage
operation
this graphic animation of its plan shows
how the huge containers on board the
ship need to be made safe and how tons
of oil could eventually be removed from
the hull
the cost of not intervening could be
astronomical but the UN is still short
of the money to finish the job
there's plenty of money available in
different member State budgets for a
response to an emergency I know if there
was an oil spill there would be tens of
millions of dollars pouring in to solve
The Spill but nobody seems to have
budget lines for avoiding a catastrophe
the scale of the threat here is enormous
if the ship breaks apart the oil spill
would take just two or three weeks to
spread all the way up to Saudi Arabia
across to Eritrea and down to the city
of Aden and this would quickly close
these key ports of hudada and Salif
ending food aid for nearly 6 million
people fuel Imports would stop too
affecting the 8 million people in Yemen
who rely on fuel powered pumps or trucks
to get their fresh water and the oil
would contaminate these desalination
pumps dotted along the coast disrupting
the supply of water to a further two
million people
on top of that the country's coral reefs
and fish stocks might never recover the
oil tanker is located in a very very
healthy coral reef and it has a lot of
species of marine organisms biodiversity
is high in that area the oil spill has
fined its way to the water column so
many Marine sensitive habitats are going
to be I mean damaged
on fso sather a threat to the ocean the
land and the vulnerable people who live
on it and a man-made crisis in waiting
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News